- What's going on?
Welcome, welcome, welcome in
to another edition of "Market Takes".
I know you could have
been anywhere in the world
on this beautiful Fed
Day out here in New York,
but you're here with me
and I appreciate that.
I'm Dion Rabouin, reporter
at "The Wall Street Journal".
We are breaking down
today's FOMC decision,
the Fed's decision, their
policy decision on rates,
the Fed choosing to raise
rates by 25 basis points.
This was really locked into markets,
but we did still see some market reaction
and we're gonna talk through all that.
Of course, we're gonna talk
about what the Fed did,
how that aligned with expectations
and the market reaction.
We're gonna talk a little
bit about the environment
coming into this report and
really how what the Fed did
moved markets and how
it could move markets
going forward into the future.
We're also gonna talk about
the Powell press conference
and what we learned from the Fed chairman,
and of course talk about what comes next
because we are always looking forward
here on "Market Takes",
and that's what we do.
So listen, before we go into
any more complicated analysis,
let's just first talk
about what happened today.
The Fed raised rates by 25 basis points.
I'm gonna throw a chart
up here on your screen
so you can see just what we're looking at
in terms of action from the Fed.
What you see there on
the right of your screen,
the rate coming up really at
the fastest pace we have seen,
a lot of folks say in modern history,
but really when you talk about
going from that zero level
to where we are now,
which is 5.25% to 5.5%,
that's really the fastest
rate when you think
about where we've come
from to where we are
that we have seen in history.
So this rate hike cycle is kind
of unprecedented in history.
And you see there just
kinda shoot straight up
for the first few months and then you get
that sort of slow down and
it looks more like an arc,
more like what you had seen
before in those previous cycles.
You'll also notice there
that those recession
shadings are in there.
You see the 2001 recession,
that 2008 global financial crisis
and the Great Recession as it's known,
and then that 2020 COVID recession,
the shortest ever in history.
Those all tend to coincide
with when rates are higher.
That doesn't necessarily mean
that the high rates caused the recession
or that we necessarily have
to have a recession now,
but do keep in mind, with rates,
as you see there on the
right of your screen,
the highest they have been since 2001,
that is definitely something
to keep an eye out for
because the economy struggles
with those higher rates.
It's harder for businesses
to borrow money.
It's more expensive, harder
for folks to borrow money
by borrowing against their
home with those home loans.
And so it's harder for
people to get credit,
harder for businesses to grow,
harder to pay off some of
those debts and those things,
and so that tends to
lead to a slower economy
and a lot of times drives
the economy into recession.
That's not what the Federal
Reserve wants to see.
That's not what the data shows us,
but it is something to
just keep your eye out for.
And this chart really just
illustrating how far we've come
in terms of raising rates and
getting 'em to that high level
that you see there, 5.25
to 5.5% where we are today.
Really, one of the biggest
and most interesting
things about the report
wasn't even what we
heard from the Chairman.
That's usually the big blockbuster thing.
It's what we got in the Fed
statement or the FOMC statement
from the Committee, which
had almost no changes.
Usually when the Federal
Reserve makes a change,
like last month, they didn't raise rates,
they held pat, didn't raise rates at all,
This month they did. They
raised 25 basis points.
So when you get a change
in policy like that,
usually there's a long explanation.
There's, "We see this change
in the economy. We saw that.
"This moved. Our analysis has changed.
"Our view of the economy has changed."
This month's statement,
almost nothing changed
except for the fact the Fed said,
"Yeah, we raised interest
rates to five and a quarter
"to five and a half,"
which is how they'll put
it in their statement.
And they said the economy
expand or economic activity
has expanded a, quote, "Moderate
rather than a modest pace."
Other than that, no real
changes to the statement
and that was very interesting.
You really did see the
market start to take off
after the statement came out
and sort of start to come
back down a little bit
after Fed Chair Jerome
Powell started to talk
and really talk about what he
was thinking about the market.
But the statement with almost no changes
locked in some of these
market expectations,
and really you saw stock prices go up,
you saw those bond prices come down.
Both of those things
mean people are buying.
When stock prices go up,
it means folks are buying.
When bond yields go down means,
it bond prices are rising,
which means again, folks are buying.
So that was interesting
and we'll talk more about
that in just a second.
But that minimal change is unusual
when the Federal Reserve
makes a change in policy.
It typically includes
a lot of explanation.
So, what's next?
Well, what's next is data dependence.
Now, I know you all are
here on "Market Takes",
you understand the importance of the data
and you understand the
importance of the CPI, PCE,
the jobs report, all those things.
But for a lot of folks
who don't really follow
the markets that closely,
they could see some wild swings
when we get the next jobs report,
when we get this PCE
report later this week.
When we get CPI or PPI, those
could move the market a lot
because we don't really know
what the Fed wants to do.
The Fed isn't sort of hedging
in one direction or the other
the way they usually do.
Usually there'll be
market expectations for,
okay, they're saying this,
but what we really expect is a hike.
Coming into this month,
we had a 100% expectation
for at least a 25 basis point hike
and even a little bit of an expectation,
3.5% expectation for
a 50 basis point hike.
So there was no one in the
markets who thought the Fed
wouldn't raise rates today.
That was priced in.
The only question was what would they say
and how would that affect the outlook?
And really what we've heard today
was Fed Chair Jerome Powell
does not know what comes next.
He's gonna be all about inflation
data, all about jobs data,
all about retail sales
data and growth data,
all about housing data,
and thankfully we here at "Market Takes"
are gonna be here to
break it down for you.
So, please stay tuned and stick with us.
Those of you who have been
watching "Market Takes",
I know you'll keep tuning in.
Those of you who haven't,
hey, tell a friend.
You wanna want to know
what's gonna move markets
and that's gonna be what we
talk about from "Market Takes".
This really could be the first time
the Fed is truly data dependent.
It's a phrase that they've used a lot.
It's kind of been beaten
into our heads a lot,
but folks really a lot of times
don't believe in investors
and folks out there in the markets.
They say, "Yeah, yeah, they
say they'll be data dependent,"
and if this thing really over performs
and we get a lot more jobs than expected
or a lot less jobs or a supremely
or significantly negative
print, then they'll react.
But this really shows us,
and what we heard today from the Chairman,
really sets us up to where
it's all about the data.
Individual reports are gonna move markets
and are gonna move
markets across the board.
We're talking not just stocks but bonds.
We're talking currencies,
we're talking commodities.
Potentially even the crypto market
could be moved significantly
by some of these big releases.
I wanna point out one
thing the Fed Chairman said
that I don't think really got
a lot of play in the markets
but I thought this really
caught me off guard.
He talked about if we
see inflation coming down
credibly and sustainably, in his words,
then we can move down
to a neutral level or even
below a neutral level.
What that means is potentially rate cuts,
as in moving the Fed funds rate back down.
And here's why that matters,
is rate cuts are usually aligned
with the start of a big
takeoff in stock prices,
with the start of a robust
increase in stock prices
and economic activity,
and usually you see the economy takeoff,
and you see even more than that
those stock prices take off
and those other risk
assets really take off.
So Fed Chair Jerome Powell kind of saying,
"Hey, even before we see
Inflation get down to 2%,"
which has been what they've
been kind of hammering home
and pounding the table on
for the last few months,
even before we get to 2%,
we're at about 3% right now on that CPI,
but even before we get to two,
we could start to see some
rate cuts from the Fed.
He said it likely won't be this year
but you could start to see
rate cuts from the Fed.
That really hadn't been
on the table previously
before this meeting, so
that's very interesting.
He said he doesn't see that
until around 2025 or so
of inflation getting back down to 2%.
So even though inflation
might be stuck around 3%,
around two and a half,
2.7%, so on and so forth,
in those higher levels, the
Fed has said, "Not acceptable,
"not good enough.
"We won't stop there."
Now Fed Chair Powell is
saying, "Well, you know what?
As long as inflation's moving down
"sustainably and credibly," in his words,
"we could start to cut rates
"maybe as soon as early next year,"
and so that's a very interesting
takeaway from this meeting.
I thought it was a pretty dovish hike.
Not a supremely dovish
hike, because again,
it's all about the data,
gonna be all about CPI, PCI, or sorry,
CPI, PCE, and PPI.
That's the Producer Price Index,
but gonna be all about inflation
and it's gonna be all about retail sales,
it's gonna be all about jobs
and if those numbers are
moving in the direction
that the Federal Reserve
wants them to move.
So, let's take a look at what's going on
in the market right now.
I'm gonna put up here
on your screen a chart.
And just to show you what's
happening in the market,
we had a big deal move today.
I think, I got the Dow
up here on your screen.
So you can see that the Dow has risen
for 12 straight days
as it closed higher for 12 straight days.
Today is the 13th straight day
that the Dow Jones Industrial
Average closed higher.
That is the longest streak
we have seen since 1987.
Those of you who remember 1987
know that that wasn't exactly
a great year for the stock
market, but in the early days
before the big crash that we saw in '87,
that was a big move.
And so stocks are moving higher.
This is a move and a
winning streak for the Dow,
specifically for the Dow, not all stocks,
but for the Dow Jones Industrial Average,
the 30 stocks that make up that,
those are a lot of industrial names,
those big blue chip companies,
up higher for 13 straight days.
You see here the S&P 500 and the Nasdaq
both ending the day lower,
and what you'll also notice
is the big pickup after
the statement was released
right on here, and then
sort of coming down
as Fed Chair Jerome Powell kept talking.
And the market's kinda
recovering a little bit
but not enough to get back positive.
When we look at bonds and
the movement in bond prices,
you look at the 10 year yield here,
pretty much across the board,
this is the move you saw
from the bond market.
Right around here again
is where we're seeing
that two o'clock timeframe,
and you see bond yields just going down.
And unlike for stocks, bond
yields really staying lower
based on what the Chairman said.
You see that even for the two year here
in terms of what the action
was right around two o'clock.
Statement comes out here, and
then you see the move lower
in terms of bond yields.
It means prices are going up.
We see when we look at currencies,
we're seeing the euro going up,
which means the dollar is going down.
A weaker dollar is generally good
for those stock prices as well.
And when we look out at
commodities really quickly,
we see oil futures,
not a big reaction here
to the Fed's movement.
Right around this two o'clock timeframe,
you don't really see a big reaction
for a lot of commodities.
But again, this just
illustrating the market reaction
that we saw and that we
got overall from markets.
And that was a bullish reaction.
This was priced in, but
I think a lot of folks
didn't expect to see that
statement from the Fed
being as unchanged as it was,
and I think that's really got
a lot of folks in the markets excited.
Let's talk about the press
conference really quickly
from the Fed Chairman.
The Chairman's really,
he said data dependence,
and I think he meant it this time.
There have been some other
times he said data dependence
and folks were like,
"Yeah, yeah, yeah, sure, data dependence."
This time I think it's really real.
Stocks have been booming
over the last couple months,
and this was kind of the one thing
that could've gotten in the way,
but now we've got a
number of other hurdles
potentially in the path for
the stock prices to rise.
But again, a number of things
that could boost stocks even further.
The Dow has only been up
about six or 7% year to date,
so it hasn't been a huge takeoff
even though the move
has been overwhelmingly
in one direction.
But we haven't seen the Dow
just take off and explode
the way the Nasdaq has.
The Nasdaq is up over
30% so far this year,
close to 35% just year to date
and we're close to the end of July.
We haven't seen that move from the Dow,
but definitely a positive
momentum going into this meeting,
and there'll be positive momentum
I think coming outta this.
Want to talk about what I've
termed soft landing summer.
Let's put a chart up here on
your screen really quickly
just to show you what I mean,
because it really can be encapsulated best
with one piece of data.
This is the CPI, the Consumer Price Index,
and you see those numbers.
Since June 2022, that's that
high bar you see up there
around 9% just coming down consistently.
And now we're at 3%, close to,
that's the lowest level we
had seen since early 2021.
And really that's exactly
what the Fed wants to see.
And this is how the retail
sales data is looking.
The jobs report is sort of
looking similar to this,
where the number of jobs
added each month is declining,
but you're not seeing just a tanking.
You're not seeing these
numbers end up in the gutter
or really just start turning negative.
What you're seeing is a soft
landing, a deceleration,
a steady decline towards
more normal levels.
And this chart I think really says it all.
It illustrates what we've
seen from inflation,
which is inflation
getting up and being high
and then coming back down,
and now being at a level
that's not quite at the Fed's target.
I don't think the mission
is accomplished yet.
I think Fed Chair Jerome
Powell would agree,
the mission is not accomplished,
but we are moving very strongly
in the right direction.
I think the Fed's message
today was if this continues,
rate cuts could be coming, and
that's definitely something
for investors who are bulls,
who are on the bullish side
of the stock market betting long equities
can get excited about.
The biggest takeaway from
the press conference I think
is the data dependence and is
just that every single piece
of data is going to be very important.
If we get a high CPI
report, if that core CPI
comes in above expectations,
that could really lead to a selloff
and you could see movement
significantly lower on the stock market.
We are just in a macroeconomic
environment right now,
where the data has consistently
been positive and solid
and told a good story
about what's happening in the US economy.
And if that continues,
I think you're gonna see
stock prices continue to rise.
You're gonna see those bond yields
continue to come down
as folks keep buying,
and that's a good thing
on the macroeconomic side.
But again, a report in the other direction
could really jolt things and
you could see an overreaction,
a knee jerk overreaction, in
a lot of markets to that data.
So you're gonna wanna know
what those data points mean
and what they say. Powell said
during his press conference,
he said, "The Fed will be data dependent."
We're gonna be dependent,
quote, "so much on the data",
and we just don't have it yet.
I thought that was a big moment
from the press conference as well.
Markets didn't react much,
but really Powell kinda locking that in.
If inflation keeps dropping
towards 2%, not to 2%,
the Fed could start cutting rates.
So, what comes next?
Well, tomorrow we have got
the second quarter GDP report.
That could, like we said earlier this week
on the market look ahead,
that could really confirm
this soft landing summer.
Expected to be right around 2% or 1.7%
when we get the number on Thursday.
If that comes in, that's again
right in line with expectations,
solidly positive, but not
too high and not too hot,
not too cold.
It's just right,
just what the data that we've
seen so far has shown us.
We also get the June PCE
inflation report on Friday.
That's in that personal
income and outlays report.
You're gonna wanna look
out for that on Friday.
That could move markets
significantly if it's high,
and if it's low, you could see markets
really start to take off.
We won't be doing
"Market Takes" on Monday.
I'm taking a little time off,
but we will be back with you next week,
so not this upcoming Monday,
but the following Monday after that.
Big jobs report coming out.
You're gonna wanna look into that.
So listen, that's gonna do it
for us here on "Market Takes".
I'm Dion Rabouin, reporter
at "The Wall Street Journal".
Thank you all so much for being with us
and we hope you'll come
back and join us next time.